failed former president Donald Trump
spoke at the NRA convention over the
weekend and it was as insane as you can
imagine and Donald Trump shows up says
nothing about we might want to restrict
some people's access to some guns and
instead says we need a panel to look at
whether trans and cannabis cause mass
shootings to convene an independent
outside panel
to investigate whether transgender
hormone treatments and ideology increase
the risk of extreme depression
aggression and even violence we have to
look at whether common
psychiatric drugs as well as genetically
engineered cannabis and other narcotics
are causing psychotic breaks